today I'm super excited to be joined by
Andy Samberg Anders is a research fellow
at Oxford University's future of
humanity Institute which is this amazing
Institute that is looking into really
big picture questions of our time things
like what is our place in the universe
and how can we best ensure a positive
future for the human race
and Alice is known as an academic
jack-of-all-trades and he certainly is
one of the most polymath we polymaths
I've ever met he originally got his PhD
in computational neuroscience but these
days spends his time spearheading
research on topics ranging from
transhumanism global catastrophic risk
emerging technologies trying to resolve
the Fermi paradox and the technological
considerations necessary for far future
space exploration thanks so much for
joining me and as there are obviously
countless topics that we could talk
about today but what I'd really like to
focus on is your upcoming book grand
futures can you give me a little bit of
an overview of what it's about
so a lot of the research we do about the
future humanity Institute deals with how
things could go badly wrong existential
risks ways we might lose out on all the
future and often people ask us but how
can you even sleep at night what
motivates you and the real reason is of
course we're pretty optimistic because
if we do survive and get their act
together which might be a slim chance
but it's still a chance then the future
looks potentially really good really big
and I'm trying to quantify that I'm not
really trying to basically figure out
how grand could be future be so what are
the kind of dimensions that you're
trying to quantify so one of the most
obvious ones is of course how far could
be spread if we go outside or how far
into space could we go but another one
is survival how far into the future
could be survive and then of course how
good could life be materially can we get
hold of matter and energy to produce a
really wealthy civilization that's also
sustainable and then very interesting
questions like how much computation can
we do how much lives could we be what
are the limits
on how good things could be in a moral
or aesthetic or and that some other
philosophical cells so with the question
how many lives there could be I suppose
the sort of parameters they've got to
look at what is the energy availability
that's required to sustain a life so
have you come to any numbers of how many
of an upper bound of how many lives
could exist yeah but it all depends on
what you mean by a life of course so
this all began actually in the 1611 hook
the guy who invented the microscope he
also wrote a little essay about how many
people could live on earth so based on
modern agriculture in the 1600s in the
Netherlands he estimated the owner about
10 to 13 billion people which it's not
weird
seems like we're going to plateau at
around 11 billion yeah something like
that
but people have been using this estimate
henceforth in all sorts of ways though
typically you try to calculate the kind
of agriculture you think make sense and
then you calculate how many people can
live on it if you're more dumi
environmentalist you say well our
current demand in Co system can't take
it you need smaller populations and if
you're a real taking optimists that you
might say actually the screw V ecosystem
let's play a plant soybeans across all
the land surface and turn them and
oceans into alkyl forms and now we can
have 10 trillion people living so more
colleges somewhere so it all depends on
how much nature you accept there right
but of course you could say that's just
one planet Earth is relatively small
what if we went out and settle other
places so you can use this kind of
reasoning but you should always be
careful about future generation might
not want to live like that but certainly
we could take the asteroid belt and turn
that into habit if I could house at
least a few trillion people that's
already quite a lot of people and of
course that's going to last for a long
time too because then at least up until
the point where the Sun becomes a red
giant in about 5.2 billion years they
are going to do pretty well and of
course if you live in space habitats
maybe remove some of them to other solar
systems and in the Milky Way got 300
billion stars right and each one has
roughly one planet
at least one planet probably more and
probably a lot of asteroids in our
building material so this already
produces some astonishingly large
numbers you multiply a kind of billions
of people per planet or trillions of
people per solar system with hundreds of
billions of solar system and that's one
galaxy and we can reach earn a few
billion galaxies too
a really common way of thinking about
the different stages of possible
civilizations that either we could have
or an alien civilization that's suitably
technologically advanced is the
Kardashev scale as I understand it a
Kardashev level one civilization we're
not there yet but we're sort of halfway
halfway there right where basically the
definition is that a civilization that
has managed to harness their sort of
energy potential of its home planets
that I can see how we could get to
relatively easily but stage 2 is where
you managed to harness the energy of
your local star so how would a
civilization go about doing that how
would we do that
well we have already started in
ourselves we have some satellites
orbiting the Sun with solar panels it
just but that's a very first small step
we could imagine adding more and more
solar panels to space and eventually use
cover of entire Sun you have an orbiting
sphere of orbiting panels this is called
the Dyson Sphere of the Freeman Dyson
physicist who suggested that we should
look for them a science of advanced
civilizations out in space and what
would they look like well that's the fun
thing because you would probably just
see this opaque sphere that would be
picking up all the sunlight and turning
it into useful work but then eventually
it becomes of course waste heat so it
would have a temperature that's
basically averages out so his
calculations was what was that it was
about earth temperature at 300 Kelvin
but that's kind of arbitrary but you
would expect it to be an infrared source
so since this is not a solid shell it's
actually a swarm of orbiting things you
might see glints of sunlight through
right so through the gaps yeah and if in
fact if you want to keep a planet but
you kind of
life can cherish maybe you can have the
solar panel tilt straight towards the
Sun when they pass through so you might
have earth orbiting outside the shell
and getting all the sunlight so you
might have your opening sending off
light right at the same time I can
imagine you could really focus that
light - yeah
so of course you could play around with
mirrors but it's probably even more
effective you take these solar panels
and now you have noticed 10 to the 26
watts of power and maybe you use it to
power a laser for example well of course
the ultimate version of a kid the frying
ants with a magnifying glass might be
focusing that laser on some remote
planet which is not going to be good for
the planet
so interstellar warfare it couldn't do
that but it's actually surprising a
crack before interstellar warfare and
which is probably very good news
basically you probably want to use that
energy for more peaceful applications
but you can of course send signals over
long distances which is easy because you
have a receiver where you let you know
where they are but if you want to kind
of attack somebody you also need to know
where to focus about it so having an
enormous large sphere with lasers on you
can focus actually very shortly but you
need to know where it is so a planet is
Alyssa Tory but suppose now people are
running away in a spaceship randomly a
chain of course they're light-years away
so you play any little thing and you can
try sweeping around your laser but space
is big so this is actually pretty good
news and one thing I've been interested
in the book is all the physical limits
to warfare how much damage can you do
how much can you protect yourself
against and one of the nice pieces of
news is that space is so big but it's
actually very hard to do damage if you
don't know where to aim damaging effect
in fact most of our matter is probably
pretty fragile if somebody knows where
it is but if you can hide really well in
space now you could of course imagine -
dyson sphere's shooting lasers at each
other but again they're intended to be
good at picking up energy and you might
not actually you might burn out a few of
its panels it's actually again fairly
inefficient so I would expect that
advanced civilizations if they want to
go to war by using other means what you
really want the Dyson Sphere for is of
course to
computations to run your computers or
maybe a power your spacecraft because
you can accelerate spacecraft or just
run your homes
whatever the homes are like how would
you extract so just to because we have
this beautiful moment lobe here that we
can use is actually a Venus but let's
assume it's the Sun because it looks
similar right so to explain for the
viewers you would harvest some kind of
body that's close to the star so in our
case mercury I guess is the nearest body
I'm kind of hungry for mercury but we
might want to start with vas per a bell
to bell so far away you've got to get I
guess you can just use the gravity to
put it in quite easily you don't have to
do your having the interesting problem
though because gravity doesn't just pull
an orbiting Astra has a velocity that
you need to get rid of for it to get
close to the Sun right it's kind of
ironic the change in velocity you need
to get close to the Sun it's quite much
bigger than you need to get to - well
the reaches of a solar system but there
is a nice thing you can do here you need
to slow it down but what you can do is
you take that asteroid you mind material
from it and in particular you mind a lot
of aluminium over metal and make a big
so let's say I'm gonna use sunlight to
slow it down and now you don't need to
waste any matter for a rocket exhaust it
takes a while because sunlight is a
fairly weak force but now you can spiral
inwards to put them into place but
personally if I want to quickly get the
Dyson Sphere I would take mercury I
would put in some robots on the surface
they have solar panels there's a lot of
sunlight on Mercury they mined the
material they make more solar panels
more robots and keep on doing this and
it turns out that after a few decades
what started as a few robots by now of
course if I cover the entire surface and
the remaining this upper layer all the
time at this point it becomes very
tricky actually both to cool down
mercury because if it's so much industry
going on and just the robots are getting
into voting in the way for each other so
there are some logistical problems that
need to be solved but basically takes
about 40 years of exponential growth -
totally disassembled mercury and with
Mercury provide enough well the
materials I don't know how thick you
just solar panel would be so so that
depends very much on what style or Dyson
Sphere you want to so if we want the
kind of normal thick solar panel mercury
is a bit woozy you might want some other
planet Venus might be in trouble
but you can also do things that are much
lighter so one elegant solution is to
use really really thin aluminium foil if
it's fin enough the light pressure of
the Sun will exactly counterbalance
gravity so it will just hang there
it doesn't even orbit now for that you
only need a biggish asteroid like Vesta
now math in itself is fairly useless
except as a decoration you get the
ultimate Christmas bauble but now you
can use these panels you tilton slide it
to focus sunlight onto some black body
that gets very hot and when you connect
that to something on the outside a
cooling element and now you have a heat
flow a lot of heat flowing through and
this way you can only get a lot better
in fact you could do this out of iron
and steam and do a steampunk Dyson so
steampunk Dyson Sphere that I can't
picture but I want to exist very much
yeah it would be pretty awesome and it
might very well be but really advanced
civilizations once we did the first
Titans fear so as we're dead serious
about that now we have extra resource
starting to the artistic ones funny ones
yeah the meme dyson sphere's so you have
this sort of presumably close to
spiracle shell at some radius away from
the Sun how do you extract that energy
and get it somewhere meaningful I do do
they have wires between them what are
you going to do so people have been the
interested in beaming power in space for
a long while so solar panels on RF have
this problem that it's actually night
half of a time well not if you go to
Sofia for north and south but still well
on average is still kind of night half
of the time even after the north
but the idea would be let's put them
into orbit and then they'll use
microwaves to beam it down to receiver
station
the little problem is that a lot of
people say wait a minute microwave beams
from space oh dear that sounds scary
yeah so actually getting is to work it's
both technically hard you lose a lot of
conversions from the solar panel to the
receiver and you still need to convince
the neighbors but this is a safe idea
so it seems tricky but in the Dyson
Sphere this probably makes a lot of
sense because now you don't have so many
places to fry you are deliberately built
it up you might want to use lasers or
other in their systems to for more
intense energy transmission so it might
be that you have a lot of space habitat
among the solar panel so you beam in
energy to them so you have either your
solar panels producing electricity and
sending things over or you have this
well maybe not steam engines but you
actually use thermal and solar energy
and it might be that the panel's
themselves contain the civilization
because of the backside you have just
computers because it's not the tiny
obvious but that one see we said we want
to stay flesh and blood it might very
well be that many of them decide to
become software and live as a kind of
solid-state civilization and then in
which case you just want optimized for
computational power yeah and and so in
that situation would a civilization even
have a desire to then go onto the next
step which we haven't talked about you
know becoming a type three civilization
which has basically harnessed the power
of the entire galaxy so every single
star yeah it's an interesting question
because some people think that oh it's
so obvious but we're all gonna upload
into computers and live inside these
servers and play World of Warcraft or
whatever until the end of time and that
explains why we're not seeing any aliens
but probably with that is it assumes
that everybody really really wants to do
that not just every human but every
individual alien in every possible alien
civilization logical prediction that's
both right a lot of value systems to
assume that you know
and it might be but the vast minority
actually are very content to live inside
the servers or do whatever we do but
it's enough at the tiny minority wants
to go out there for things to happen
it's a bit like our current civilization
we tremendously rich compared to our
ancestors in the Neolithic and while
most of us are spending the resources in
normal ways some of us do we are the art
projects or in the innovation and do
things that change the world it's
timeless that most people are totally
normal on the mainstream but those edges
yeah I mean there's two people who also
choose to live in sort of 1700 C so
indeed it's kind of a good backup to
have them it might turn out of it that
we're doing something very bad and by
going high-tech so we should have
backups diversity of preference yeah
indeed that's an important thing when
thinking about grand futures when I
start describing encapsulating stars
into solar panels a lot of people
shudder and are you to be the first say
think I haven't even started but they
already feel bad it's horrifying
disassembling planets it's totally
because we don't want the grand feel
they want a modest future they imagine
having tea with the big carry while
people are playing cricket on the
village green in some nice sensible
village with reasonable social relations
I think that's a fairly calm on the view
and I think we should totally make sure
people can live like life's like mad so
that's why we might want to keep the
earth and make sure it gets sunlight
even if a lot of others go world and
colonize the Dyson Sphere and similarly
with the others who are not content to
live virtually they might want to go out
there into the big dork and do other
grand things yeah so the next step then
so let's say we've got to the stage
where we've harnessed the majority the
sun's power and we can use that to now
extend out to local star systems and
beyond how would we go about that so if
you're very patient you can just send
something using 1970s technology the
Voyager probes if we had aimed most
likely differently would have
transported the Voyager probes own
battle act with music to another solar
system it's just that they're not aimed
in anywhere particular and it's not
going to arrive very very
functional maybe the black is going to
be intact but none of the computers and
technology work but in principle if you
are willing to spend a few tens or
hundreds of thousands of years of
Transport you can do it using very
low-tech things but if we assume we're a
bit more impatient you can use of course
about energy from a Dyson Sphere to
accelerate things are much higher
velocity so I calculated together with
my colleague Stuart Armstrong but you
need about six hours of sunlight to send
probes not just to know all the stars in
the Milky Way but to all the reachable
galaxies what how well basically what
you do is that you either use a coin gun
that is you have electromagnetic coins
and you magnetically accelerate a
projectile it's a bit similar to railgun
but where you have an electrical
connector and since it's moving very
fast things get very hairy to actually
get this to hold together while talking
about this eric drexler the point of who
was sitting next to me point out Oh kids
today they don't know how to build
proper interstellar probes they point
out that lasers are probably even better
if you have the right kind of laser very
finely tuned for the right kind of
receiver crystal then you can actually
accelerate just using light light
pressure and use a lot of power to
accelerate on a solar cell line sale
yeah and you can do it in various ways
so there is the breakthrough starshot
initiative that actually aims that
within a few decades and the these small
microchip light probes to Proxima
Centauri using a big laser now if you
have a Dyson Sphere you can be make
bigger lasers much bigger laces but it's
might still just be a good idea to send
very small probes because when you're
moving very fast if you meet a big grain
of dust that collision is going to be
oops
yeah of course and so what sort of
fractions of light speed are we talking
yeah so breakthrough starshot thinks
about that 20% is a doable
which is ambitious given our current
technology but there are good people and
they are thinking through of engineering
is engaged approximate Centauri in just
over 20 years yeah but it's going to
take a while to get to Andromeda this
way yes so I think you can definitely
get
to at least 90 or even 99% of lightspeed
you need to do some interesting
engineering the problem is of course the
dust issue becomes Nastya Nastya the
force do you go not only the dust but
also the gas in interstellar space
normally we will say oh that's just
hydrogen gas hang around but now it's
going to appear like a proton beam
hitting my spacecraft head-on yeah so
you better have good cell prepare or you
sell a lot of small craft and don't mind
but a few Aloha giving away okay so this
is all for sort of probes that we could
send out to presumably gather
information send it back to us and so on
but what about physically transporting
biological matter is that even doable I
don't know and I think it's going to be
very tough if you can build a Dyson
Sphere you can probably actually make a
classic starship and send the biological
people but it's going to take a lot more
resources it's going to be one of those
real ambitious things but they're
probably not that cost-effective because
the problem is of course moving very
fast okay now you have a lot of risk and
you need a lot of shielding and
radiation is not going to be good for
biological people and even then you need
an enormous amount of reaction mass to
slow down at the destination so
personally I think the mode it's most
likely the biological you must never
leave a solar system but we might be
sending these small probes with enough
normal technology to land on an asteroid
again I'll fill the solar panels little
bit the robots me remaining stuff and
building more robot solar panels and
turning that into industry but when can
i maybe make a habitat and then you're
actually artificially put together cells
and create a little biosphere and put
people in there
this of course presupposes that you have
good enough normal technology to do this
with a small seed program but we kind of
have a demonstration already in form of
in acorns and acorn is a little proceed
but can generate multi-tone oak it just
takes a few decades or centuries and a
lot of sunlight human well the vision
you could probably hide via human
genetic material inside that it's just
like we don't have the biotechnology to
make acorns that make humans we
is an interesting mildly disturbing idea
but you could imagine non-technology
doing the same thing if you can actually
make things on a molecular level it's no
problem with actually putting in one of
the UK and in two and then if you
according to some calculations I did I
think there is enough space to store
been here on state of all people in the
UK inside an acorn sized computer this
is still presuppose a pretty advanced
for nanotechnology but we have plenty of
time to develop that and you of course
you need those robot nannies etc to
actually real people right so an
environment so it's going to require a
fairly high technological level it's
harder to analyze this than solar
collectors but I think one can make a
pretty strong case but this is
physically possible because we see a lot
of very similar processes and one can
then delve into what we do we need to
build and discover so let's say we can
get to the stage we could send a probe
out to neighboring star systems that can
plant a seed of life that then grows a
new colony there how long could it take
to sort of spread across the entire
Milky Way are there just gaps that are
too big to you know because our locals
our nearest neighbor is from what four
light-years away
but presumably some of those gaps are
much larger right yeah so that's a very
interesting issue because it might be
that it's not that much dust that we can
make their resilient space probes in
which case we can just go all the way
but the time it takes is just going to
depend on how fast we can go but it's
not implausible but at least inside the
galaxy there's too much dust at least if
you try to move along with disk if you
look up at the Milky Way in a really
good place you can see this dark dust
lanes that is because all the light from
the stars of our beside get hit a dust
particle most of that absorption is by
tiny ones but probably don't disturb the
probes but embedded in that there might
be more dangerous ones so it might be
that you can't go that far before
hitting something which means what you
need to move over shorter distances now
if we could only travel let's say one
light year we would be stuck here we
couldn't get there over to Proxima
Centauri if we could move four light
years we could get over two
some on Alpha Centauri but I don't think
there is anything else but we could
reach if we could reach a bit further
out we get a few more stars and then
something magical happens about the
seven to eight light-years of distance
suddenly we can reach a fair number of
stars and many of them also have other
stores and we can spread across
essentially most of the disk of the
Milky Way so this is called a
percolation transition it comes from
studies of how liquids diffuse through
and their powders it started in geology
when people were drilling oil wells but
it turns out in an astonishing amount of
mathematics and physics it's really
wonderfully beautiful and you can apply
it here to spreading through space so
there is a kind of distance limit can we
move beyond that one we can get most of
the galaxies Wow so there of course
going to be a few weird stars above and
below the disk that we can't reach this
way of course if you're patient enough
stars move around and some move in and
out of range and then of course we have
our galaxies again we have big gaps
we're now talking about thousands to
millions of light-years but if you can
bridge that we can get together once the
maloca cluster I calculate that if we
can move some tens of millions of light
years when we can reach other galaxies
clusters and basically take over the
entire cosmic web we can spread
everywhere except maybe for a few places
inside big galactic voids so what kind
of time frames are we talking here in
terms of settling even the local cluster
of galaxies so I think it's pretty
plausible that we can move at a fair
fraction of light speed and given that
the local class of galaxies is about 2-3
million light years across
that would mean maybe in between 4 & 6
million years if we move at half light
speed which is a lot of time on our
current human time scale but
astronomical is infinite and the Milky
Way well it's about a hundred thousand
light years across if we count some of
the outskirts and again at the half
light speed but just two hundred
thousand years even if we go much more
slowly it takes a thousand years between
each trip and when you spend some
hundreds of years on each settled planet
and then build new spacecraft with
some tens of millions of years the disk
of the Milky Way
I mean either way it seems if we can get
the technology to do it then it's it's
going to be no problem in terms of you
don't need to worry about the universe's
time limits you know you know this
delivers era ending and things like heat
death and so on uh so so far away right
we're almost certainly almost but not
quite so the problem is the local
galactic cluster we can do in a jiffy
getting over to the Virgo cluster well
that's going to take a bit longer
because now we're talking about hundreds
of millions of light years but it's
still in the neighborhood but suppose we
start aiming at really remote galaxy
clusters so we send off our spacecraft
as close to light speed as we can but
while it's going there maybe a billion
light-years away
expansion happens so you it gets further
and further away and the relative
velocity decreases so if you time it
nicely you end up going there with zero
velocity you can start with light speed
and you just park next to it oh you
don't need to worry about deceleration
or no retro rockets around the other
complication the problem is if you're a
man little bit too far away it runs away
from you so there is an upper distance
we can reach
it's about 4.9 gigapower six away but is
about thirteen billion light-years so
it's a lot but that is a limit we can
see galaxies of our sight but we can
never ever touch right well of course
because the ones that we're seeing are
ones that we're looking 1213 billion
light years into the past anyway so
presumably some of those are now already
far beyond our reach yes a things get
slightly complicated because of
expansion of the universe has not been a
constant thing so it started out slowing
down and then it began accelerating
again so there are complications about
these distance measures which it caused
endless headache when you try to keep
them straight but still but it means
that we can only get a part of
observable universe but parts of the
universe that we never ever affect but
we can still see them right of course
yeah yeah causally we can't have any
impact but we're still getting the
information from
past yeah so obviously this is getting
pretty hypothetical is that a type 4
civilization so Kardashev scheme started
with 2 type 1 the civilization that took
all the energy on one planet and then
the type 2 which would be the Dyson
Sphere one a type 3 civilization would
in his scheme be somebody using all the
energy of all the stars in a galaxy and
we have actually heard experimental
experimental is looking for them so
there was the J hat survey looking at
about 500 thousand galaxies trying to
see is there something all the way to
star light coming from these galaxies
like if there was a lot of Dyson spheres
around them sadly none of us showed up
someone when we looked we really weird
but didn't look like Dyson spheres so
there are probably no Type three
civilizations around us we would
probably have noticed so maybe we are
going to be the first but you could
imagine of course being even more
ambitious so you go out there and you
settle all the galaxies you can settle
and now you are a type 4 civilization
but perhaps not for long because that
darn expansion nice but your galaxy
classes get separated so it becomes
harder and harder to talk to evaporate
parts of the civilization and in about 3
to 400 million years basically we all
get separated into their own little
island universes and that's what she
raises an interesting question like if a
civilization becomes so large and the
distances between them so vast is it
even still a civilization anymore if it
can't communicate with us yeah I I think
that communication is necessary to call
it one civilization
you could still imagine that we decide
that okay we're gonna spread the happy
life's across we start the measure of
utility is going to be happiness so we
spread a happy life or to all the
galaxy's we can reach and then they
drift apart and you have all these
little happy the island universe if we
can never talk to each other but they
kind of Wiggly know that there are happy
guys out there and this is really really
great
so that civilization might still be
thinking about yeah we can't talk to
barbers but it works well but you could
imagine another value system saying
actually a civilization need to be
communicating because it's a culture
it's supposed to think deep thoughts
create artifacts do things together in
that case you print might only want to
have a galactic super cluster that keeps
together the rest of the universe is
kind of beside the point
or you can be really ambitious and say
let's enlarge that cluster so we are
going to the outside of it and sending
matter back to build make it bigger so
we can last longer right your talk about
moving galaxies yep how it all starts
with a lot of aluminium foil okay yes
really
so one way of moving the tin hat people
were right yeah ultimate tin foil hat
but it's used to send beams rather than
the deflector okay so what you do is you
take a hemisphere of aluminium foil and
put it around the storm a bit like the
Dyson Sphere but just on one side and
then you reflect the Starlight in one
direction this is a exceedingly busi
rocket early we have been talking about
actual Rockets are using powerful lasers
now we're using just starlight to try to
move a storm the velocity change it just
floats on pressure reflecting back
that's slowly slowly and that is the
trick of course because it's cheap you
can keep on doing this for a long time
and on average if you keep it up for
about four million years you will have a
close encounter with another storm and
the stores will of course effect each
other gravitationally and change orbits
so it's a very very slow grand
sheepherding yes indeed of stars and
galaxies well that's the tricky part
so the the stars when you just move them
with these so-called slant of trusters
or moving relatively slowly but they
have relative velocities in orbiting but
of tens of kilometers per second and now
when they move faster you can direct
them to do other gravitational assets so
it's not just cheaper it might be the
ultimate pinball because you can
accelerate stars by having removed past
the binary store and get some extra
energy to speed it up and you can put
energy into the binary store by moving
on Bob result and you cannot complicated
free body interactions if you want to
delay a bunch of stars because there
later and you can also throw stars out
of a galaxy with enormous speed by
having a post close to the central black
hole so we actually see bits naturally
happening and there are hyper velocity
starts moving fast sense of km/s because
we've been yes because we've been
unlucky enough to almost fall into the
black hole now you could imagine use of
this as a really absurd rocket you're
sending stars past my black hole and
expelling them at an enormous velocity
this could actually move my milky way 50
kilometres per second enough to somewhat
dodge and dramatic galaxy which is
careening towards us and it's going to
hit us in a few billion years the
problem is that's going to use up most
of its stars I think the stores actually
are a really valuable part the dark
matter and we have we we can't see any
good use of it right now maybe a future
generation would totally laugh at me
saying this because very realized the
dark matter is actually valuable stuff
and stores who cares but from a current
perspective if they think that stores of
this stuff we care about what we do is
we turn the store semi galaxy to
hypervelocity sort and send them to
better that the galaxy cluster we
building so you essentially have
galaxies depleted of stars sending
streams of stars against expansion of
universe slowing them down and then
hopefully parking them well I wouldn't
want to be traffic control for this
project it's a hectic it's a hectic it
might of course but it literally takes
billions of years so it might be hectic
on bad timescale it might still be a bad
kind of it goes millions of years before
each arrival but still you could build
up much bigger galaxy clusters this way
so if your super civilization really
wants to have a lot of mass mass energy
that they can use in the very far future
as the stars go out and you need to turn
that the mass into actually energy to
power yourself this is probably way to
do it and we can be pretty certain
nobody else is doing it in the visible
universe because this would be very
noticeable I mean something would be up
in all telescopes so if we got to that
stage that would make us a type for yeah
Carter chefs on the consciousness scale
is there a type 5 be honest
so people have occasionally randomly
suggested some say type 4 use all of
energy in the universe but we
can't reach the rest of the universe
right assuming of course but we write
about acceleration expanding and the
dark energy which given the fact that we
have known about or can you for just a
few decades and are still very uncertain
what it is we might be really wrong
about this maybe advanced civilizations
just find a way of getting around that
and then they can get much more of a
universe to do something with you could
of course imagine what about other
universe all the ways of sneaking over
to them I'm skeptical of that being
possible but again who knows it's worth
noticing that we have discovered quite a
lot of things just the past 500 years of
the discovery of experimental method and
science and over the next five hundred
years we can probably expected this gave
quite a lot of equally or shattering
things and over the next five million
years which is still barely time to get
to the local cluster of galaxies science
has probably advanced to a really
extreme level so maybe for type five or
six and hundred civilizations out there
but we can only analyze what we know
about right now right so in terms of
trying to quantify this um you mentioned
before there is an upper limit to how
many possible human lives could exist
what's your upper bound so my upper
bound is somewhere slightly north of a
googol future human lives for 10 to 100
yes and the way I'm arriving at this is
that I'm looking at how much mass energy
is fair in the universe but we can
access and then assuming maybe you
convert that as efficiently as you can
into computation and they assume that
people are running as computations which
is of course a few big IFS then you end
up with on the order of about 10 to 100
future lives of course it might be but
very very long life so then it's going
to be a few fewer people or it might be
that a lot of them are very brief or
there might be a different ways of
organizing we're talking about the very
advanced post human civilization here
but the number is really large that's an
important portal so if that's actually a
feasible number that could be achieved
then it really speaks for the importance
of what we do now right because we are
at this really interesting juncture
where
we could go extinct I mean a paper
produced by the future of humanity
Institute I think it was 15 20 years ago
put the estimate at somewhere around
twenty nineteen twenty percent of
extinction by the end of 2100
I don't know has that number been
revised well if the numbers should be
taken with an astronomically large a
grain of salt because basically the
probability is big enough that it's
worth worrying about even if it was just
one percent risk that's worse than a lot
of things we actually do worry quite a
bit about right and it's worth noticing
but this enormously large number even if
you say yeah right I don't think you can
upload people then I will say yeah but
we can still fill all these galaxies
with organic people and somebody might
even say yeah right I don't even believe
you can build those normal machines and
those space probes we have to set the
full solar system and then I would say
well a trillion people living for five
billion years that's an awful lot of
people even if you'd go to be a super
modest fee say we have a hundred million
people living simple happy lives for
let's say 800,000 years which would mean
that humanity survives a million years
which is kind of typical per mammal
still 100 million times eight hundred
thousand that's an awful lot more people
than exists today and have ever lived
the future even at its most modest is
vastly bigger than the present and I
think actually the average future
probably is towards the Google on the
other side right and I mean people you
know there's always a lot of discussion
and in terms of you know how much do we
value a future life that doesn't exist
yet but it's likely to compare to a life
a life that is present right now but I
mean everyone cares about even their
unborn children one generation away even
if you have a sort of a scaling factor
down again when you multiply this sort
of value with the number of the sheer
number of possible lives the outweigh
all the lives that we have today the the
moral weight is enormous yeah and and
that many people of course don't do a
calculation like this we just feel and
it's interesting because future
generations cancer
very bloodless but sometimes we have
this experience but we don't want to
break the chain and so a while ago not
to dam Cathedral had a fire and a lot of
people were really emotionally taken by
it and it's interesting why in some
sense that's just a dead inanimate
object but of course as a symbol for
human aspiration for culture and indeed
generations toiling away as making well
everybody realize oh that's it's a great
loss we really need to restore it and
then of course we can argue about how to
restore it but we have similar projects
going on all around us when people are
rearing the children they actually hope
they very children will have children
and so on when people are writing papers
it's not just that it's going to be good
for your career but ideally but this is
a valuable contribution to mankind when
you make art or anything
a lot of that assumes that there is a
long range future and I think the risk
of us going extinct here the dawn of
history that's worth taking seriously
that's why we really need to be careful
figure out ways of make yourself more
resilient avoiding the most stupid risks
spreading me out maybe a bit so we
reduce the risks a lot so we have a
chance of getting to these grand futures
notice what I haven't been talking about
what be super-severe said I really do
because I have no kid I can't predict
what the cultural values are going to be
50 years from now maybe their goal is to
just find out some ultimate truth of the
universe and then they're done yep or it
might be but at that point the rails
whoa we've been going in the wrong
direction all the time now we need to do
these other things it's very hard to
predict future ideas because if we could
then we would already have them
so future societies might go off in all
sorts of direction we can outline using
physics and the bit of is exploratory
engineering I've been going on about a
bit of a limits and that tells us a bit
of a size they can be in but where we
actually choose to go that's up to them
and of course to some extent up to us
because we are setting the start here
right but it's arguably our moral duty
to give them the opportunity to be able
to make those decisions yeah we should
aim at have a kind of open-ended future
do
would be horrible if we change them down
with what we think is really great
because if we think back in history what
previous civilizations would have done
that's probably not very good by our
standards one of other favorite phrases
I ever read it's just one simple
sentence and it is love is that which
enables choice because it's something
that provides maximum optionality and
that's and he's certainly in my opinion
what we should be trying to do now is is
give it as maximum runway as we can to
our descendants in order to we assume
they're gonna have better knowledge than
us better you know ability to use
resource and reason and so on to come to
better moral decisions than us so we
just have to make sure that we give them
the opportunity to do that to exist in
the first place yeah
and once we exist then they can really
make the future grand yeah absolutely
so coming back to earth a little bit
right now we've got you know visionaries
like you know masks
I think Bezos and some of the other sort
of technologists who are looking into
ways to advance space technology with
the goal of getting as multiplanetary
what do you think is sort of the most
important priority in terms of the steps
we should be taking right now to do that
is it the moon is it Mars I don't know
really I'm I personally rather fond of
Anna mining asteroids and the moon is
nearby but Mars besides having awesome
fantasy names for all the locations and
being a much more of a place than the
moon and asteroids
it also has practically all we know we
need to build a civilization it might be
that on the asteroids you might need the
one type of asteroid to get some
resource and another type to and
therefore by other resources so it might
be slightly more awkward to mine but the
first thing we need is making it cheap
to get to space so we can start
experimenting the reason we have been so
bad that settling space has been
partially but you can't do much
experimentation if every kilogram you
need to send to space it could have been
made out of the gold for we know because
it's so expensive you need to make it
cheap enough so people can start trying
out things because the way with typical
advanced technologies we may
some carefully planned and when we try
it and then it doesn't work and we learn
from that and fix it the problem is up
until now it has always been it must
work so we spend an enormous amount of
effort on design which means that you
can't really be very flexible you can't
actually figuring things out and to make
a mining robot for an asteroid you will
need to have a device that can handle
gravel getting into the gears and if you
need to plan for gravel in big ears on
earth that's going to be a very slow
development and we also need to have a
good business plan for space and this is
worried I think Mises might have more
ideas than masks masks is kind of taking
a lot of money is earning on earth to
get to Mars but it doesn't look like is
planning to earn a lot of money by being
on Mars what we saw seems to be
interesting vicious that you find in the
70s for Gerald O'Neill and others at
NASA about actually building space
habitats a building space industries
Neil pointed out but actually the
planetary surface is probably the worst
place you can have an industrial
civilization that's where you want your
National Park that's where you want to
people you want to put the industry
somewhere else of course the problem of
putting industry in space is you also
need to send down products etc for for a
foreseeable future I think most space
industries going to supply in a space
industry and space settlements on their
own so it's getting a good business
model space is really hard so in terms
of reducing existential risk long-term
settling of many planets and ideally an
asteroid is really the way forward short
term is probably not the most cost
effective way of reducing sizzurp risk
we could probably make do with using
that money for reducing pandemic risk
and nuclear war risk but one of the cool
things about space is that they can
motivate useful research by the sheer
cachet of space if I were to suggest but
let's make self-contained greenhouses
solar-powered but using hydroponics can
grow food in any environment and I
suggest that this is a great way of
helping people in arid environments in
developing countries many people say oh
that's lovely others but I wouldn't get
any money saying this is to settle space
a lot of people get the interest in the
world we should we do
and of course with nice thing is once we
go to that system that it can put on a
space station or Mars we can also put it
in the Taklamakan desert so I think
actually quite a lot of these
technologies are going to turn out to be
super useful because if you can actually
settle Mars then it can actually settle
every corner of rf2 I went to a talk
recently which discussed the viability
of building a lunar base their argument
was that it's the obvious stepping-stone
on the way to Mars gets a little bit out
of the Earth's gravity well and I heard
a cost quoted of two billion dollars to
have eminent lunar settlement which was
at least an order of magnitude less than
what I expected it to be what is your
opinion on that do you think it would be
suitable as a backup for existential
risk or is it too close I think it might
be useful as a backup if you could get
it for two billion dollars I would be
interested I also have a saw will
Marshall if you know him that's what he
said it's a really cool possibility I'm
skeptical that you can do it that
cheaply Bo and of course mega projects
generally tend to have cost overruns
that are really big and this might be
the ultimate kind of mega project which
of course makes some of the earlier
things I've been discussing about the
Dyson spheres etc look very Romanians in
terms of cost overruns but getting back
to the moon I think it's a useful test a
case having a lunar base you can put
some stuff there if you can make it
self-sustaining that's great but it's
not just what needs to be
self-sustaining needs to be able to
actually expand using local resources
without importing anything if it can do
that now it actually is a bit of a
safeguard against some existential risks
and are there are enough raw materials
on the moon in in terms of metallic
elements there and so on I don't see
much problems with the metals and the we
have found over past decade and two but
actually there is a fair bit of water
which is great what worse means nitrium
right because we made out of a fair bit
of nitrogen our plants are made out of
it yeah maybe you can replace midnight
you name the atmosphere inside the base
with some other inert gas but
nitrogen is relatively rare on the moon
and in viña solar system earth has a lot
of it but again exporting that is tricky
you can find a lot of it in the outer
solar system after all Titan got a
lovely thick atmosphere with a lot of
nitrogen which I would love to bring
over to habitat to be in a solar system
but that requires going around for FES
so I think a lunar base would have to
scrounge for nitro and a few other
elements it's going to be a fair bit of
scarcity on the moon so if I gave you a
trillion dollars what would be your plan
of action for settling space well at
first getting really cheap access to
space so that's important and then I
would probably go trying a lunar base is
not a bad the test case but I want to
mine asteroids carbonaceous chondrites
contain a lot of raw material including
a fair bit of water and organics and
then of course you want some metal
asteroids too then of course you want to
be able to automate the production of
solar panels because once you have
energy you can recycle material quite
well so making solar panels in space
might be are not very interesting
adventure because right now our standard
solar panels are made out of pure
silicon and silicon is easy to get but
we purify it by reacting with
hydrochloric acid so you need to get
chlorine and that might be a bit scarce
on some asteroid it's actually
surprising abundant of marcin but you
can make solar panels out there other
things you can of course use mirrors to
heat something and run turbines you can
use pyrite iron sulphide it's relatively
in a bad solar collector however it's
cheap and at least again on Mars you
find a lot of it and yeah I think you
can find a lot of that in asteroids team
so we have a lot of options and we
probably need to explore many multiple
options here because we don't know what
actually would work the problem is that
doing a top-down plan for how to do it
is never going to work in reality you
need to have a lot of experimentation
and that means that they need to be
cheap enough to do the experiments and
also that you can survive making
mistakes and flub it but I think I could
use up a trillion and probably get us
into space
but you probably need better project
managers and engineers than I am
so you mentioned to me earlier that
there are considerations in terms of the
metabolism on a Mars base can you
explain well in many ways you can think
of a more space as a living organism it
needs nutrients it needs energy it gets
its energy presumably from solar panels
and it takes dirt and rocks on Mars and
turns it into more more space so the
question is can you actually make
something that actually makes all its
own powers so there was a famous study
in 1979 but no several thinking about a
robotic leaving our Factory but we could
build robotic lunar factories and again
you get exponential growth and wait long
enough and you cover the entire moon
with factories that can make anything
you want that was still not getting all
the details for example is a very
important question on how you make
microchips on the moon and they actually
cheated a little bit in their analysis
on that but if we think about what we
know about Mars I think we can sketch up
but there is a metabolism for a more
space
so James Yamana who I met that there has
been Institute for physics he has been
doing some excellent work on this and
together we're now trying to extend this
so basically you want to take Martian
dirt and atmosphere and turn it into
metals to make machines you want to turn
it to do something like concrete to
build buildings you want solar panels
and microchips and you want organics
to make plastics and turns out that you
can probably do this the Martian
atmosphere is fin and made mostly carbon
dioxide and you can get water from ice
in the soil you can use your solar panel
to turn the water into oxygen and
hydrogen and then you can react that
with the carbon dioxide you can make
something called syngas which mix your
carbon monoxide and hydrogen which is
very useful for reducing in metal oxides
into methods so this is how you turn the
marsh on red sand into iron for example
and you can use this in a lot of other
things you can for example turn that
carbon in that same gas into methane by
adding even more hydrogen and then you
can polymerize it
and now you can get hydrocarbons and you
can quickly build up to all of organic
chemistry and now we have your plastics
you also want to get those chlorides
which are really bad for doing Martian
agriculture and get that flora not put
some hydrogen on it and now you are
called hydrochloric acid together with
quartz you can now in distill in a pure
silicon and make microchips and solar
panels you still need some dopants like
arsenic or phosphorus and they are
relatively rare but you don't need much
of them it actually looks like you can
get most of these materials on Mars
given what we know about standard
Martian dirt and atmosphere it's missing
very have been enough volcanism in the
past probably enough water that are
going to be some ore so if you really
want your land or uranium there is
probably that but that's going to
require more lot more surveying and
Rovers looking around for it so the
problem might be that asteroids while
lovely a source of material they're not
that differentiated when you have a
planet like Earth and Mars you tend to
get material sorted somewhat into ores
in some sense if you have enough energy
you don't care you just take around all
my material and extract but that's a lot
of heavy work normally you'd want to be
effective about this so also maybe you
don't want to dig up the whole place the
reason you go to Mars might be that you
want to actually have some pristine
nature so one of my favorite papers
produced by the future of humanity
Institute is entitled astronomical waste
and it talks about or tries to estimate
the number of you know you as you've
mentioned there's this upper bound of
perhaps of Google lives that could exist
from now into the future but every
second that passes good old entropy is
taking free energy and dissipating it
and basically taking away lives that
could exist
can you talk through a little bit about
the process of how you came to this well
you can make a rough estimation of how
many lives they exist by looking at how
far we can spread them and how long we
can survive and then make some
assumption about how much resources
different life stake and the important
thing is not what number you end up with
but it's a big number typically temp ^
something with two digits and we might
quibble a lot about how I do these
calculations but typically about the
only moves it's a few orders of
magnitude you still end up with another
big number with you in a temp to the
power of two digits and then we have
this problem we're losing universe every
year we lose about seven galaxies that
kind of fall off air in the edge of what
we can reach seven galaxies that's what
yeah each of them hundreds of billions
of stars that's kind of horrifying
energy yeah and you kind of feel like we
need to rush to build the rockets and go
there but the problem is of course that
rush might actually risk everything
because if we rush off to build the
Rockets and we accidentally destroy the
world because we're doing stupid physics
experiments or actually didn't watch the
politicians which were nuclear buttons
etc then we lose all of that that's
actually much worse than seven galaxies
per year some astronomical waste
argument points out that the future is
so big that much of the value lies in
preventing threats to all of the future
but is existential risk here in the dawn
of time we just Ultima caves
we're kind of on our way to the Rockets
but if we actually take too much risk
now that's much worse than losing some
and galaxies also it's spending some
time working on those rockets and make
them faster might be quite valuable
because if you travel too slowly the
expansion of the universe gives you a
much smaller part of universe so it
might be worthwhile to spend a million
years perfecting your Rockets and then
go really fast then try to rush things
and as thank you so much this has
certainly been one of the most
fascinating conversations I can remember
possibly in my entire life and when is
your book gonna be out well hopefully
before the technological singularity
because right now it's still expanding
and I need to kind of start bringing it
back and they find a poor editor who
can't keep it short enough for well it
certainly is a big topic if you guys
want to find out more do check out the
links below
certainly check out the future of
humanity Institute's website there's
tons of brilliant stuff to read and
there's been a pleasure thank you thank
you well folks thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this and you
want to see more things like it then
make sure you click that subscribe
button below